johnny depp case
did you hear that she pooped in his bed
and she blamed it on the dog
you're lying down she did nah she needs
to go prison just for that
psycho alert no that's actually really
nasty well why would you think it's okay
to do that like what it does there's
clearly something not okay okay there in
that whole situation for you now to go
and put your
waist on someone's bed
why don't you think
have you ever had any
men in a toxic relationship where they
don't leave and why don't you think they
leave
control
um
yeah
i think it just boils down to control
100 because of i know a few friends
who've been
who've been the aggressor in
relationships and there's literally no
reason why you're there because you're
never home you're cheating on your
partner you're being your partner you're
beating your kids but you stay because
you want you just want control i feel
like it's down to control
um you want control what do you mean so
so the girl was beating him or the other
no no the other way around so the guy
was the aggressor okay the guy was the
aggressor and she stayed because she
wants control oh why the lady well why
the woman's dancing yeah it was like all
right
i i'm not like have you ever had a guy
friend that that's happened to you oh
okay
because johnny depp was in a
relationship with her for like years
this was going on
so i'm just curious if you have any male
friends maybe not to that extent but
something like that's happened too
no no no i mean i've been well my last
ex was pretty like all my relationships
was pretty toxic i don't have i don't
know if i have any friends that have
been in a relationship
um well
toxic was like
i didn't want to like it got so bad to a
point where i didn't want to be seen in
like public with her because it's like i
go to no no it really got that bad
because what happened was when we first
started dating it was sweet you know the
honeymoon stage and it was like so funny
sunshine and giggles that's how she got
me
um
and then we got to like we got together
and she um we used to go to my like a
local bar and you know just hang out
after work you know just catch up and
stuff like that and she and then after
it got so bad to a point where like
she's like started screaming arguing in
public like i understand one thing at
home and like it's one thing right but
like when i have to look right around
when she's going to the bathroom or
she's going to order a drink or
something and people are turning around
with like
like one of those it's bad and then i
try to explain it to her but she's in
her little world like oh no no no no and
i was listening there was a camera next
to you and i showed you how many people
like you know i mean and for example
like if you keep you disappear i told us
straight up if you keep this up right
one of these days we're going to be
walking down the street and you're going
to give some smirky guy or some small
some girl that like i just look or
something i'll say something snarky
she's going to slap you in the face
you're going to be on the floor and i'm
not going to help you i'm going to look
at the guy or the girl but i listen you
just proved my point and shake his hand
and keep it stepping right because
honestly like
it got really bad like is is it what's
your point when
we broke up well i broke it off with her
like after like seriously because i was
the type of i was an optimist thinking
that like she might change
like you know keep dragging i dragged
out for 11 months i dragged it out were
you trying to fix her
no i want to say fix her just like
give her helpful advice
you know what yeah [ __ ] that she's my
yes i was trying to fix her because the
[ __ ] was crazy
i'm sorry the [ __ ] was crazy
like we couldn't go 15 minutes without
having an argument put it to that way
like it was bad
but i think it might also be that hope
that the person might change yeah and
also like emotional dependency on the
person and complacency like once you're
so used to someone and then they kind of
act up i feel like you're more okay with
staying and tolerating it than just
instantly leaving i'm not gonna lie i
told people if she gets how many was it
30
40 or 50 subs i'll get my ex on the show
and then
yeah
so guys listen did you say thirty
thousand i said no no no no no no thirty
was it fifty or sixty by the end of next
month yeah i'll try getting my eggs on
the show so guys yeah if you subscribe
hit the subscribe button right now oh
yeah fifty thousand no fifty to sixty
fifty or sixty we'll discuss all the
cameras
we'll go sixty yeah i'm i'm the one
getting roasted here sixty thousand subs
he'll bring his toxic acts on the show
and i'll interview them
now
be like why were you insane
just just or not honestly but i just
blunt it out like yeah like what's wrong
with you
what if she says you were the problem
okay cool
no that's exactly what she's gonna say i
know her because everything everything
she everything that i've done for her or
anything any problems that i wrote she
blamed me
like she got so bad like you literally
you know like in front of your parents
right like if you swear to your parents
you'll get like a backhander something
like you know i mean i don't swear in
front of my parents we went and had a
beach day lovely beach day we you know
we'll come back on the train and if she
didn't like we was having a conversation
she would disagree she started swearing
from eight in front of my mom and my
grandma
brother like you don't do that thing
like
like read the room yeah it was bad
so yeah 66 60 000 subs guys
i might hit that soon you know what if
you listen if you do cool i'm gonna hit
her up on something like you do but i
think it's like listen i'll reach out if
she wants to come and do the show that's
fine if you don't you can't blame me i
tried
okay
um what about you any stories yeah i was
gonna say like i've seen situations
where like
the girls like you say that you say the
guy's whipped because he's like
oh yeah yeah come out let's like link up
and do something
nah i can't because i'm with my girl and
that
and like
he's just like the girl's like not being
like controlling but like
she's like bet she's like rude to him
and stuff like
and like he's just taking it i feel like
yeah that's that's a situation where
i've seen like a toxic relationship
but like
i feel like people stay in certain toxic
relationships because they've got like
that if you've got a child now it's like
you you've got to try and make it work
or more
if you get married quick let's say
you've only noticed about two years you
get married you've got to sort of stay
of that person or now you live together
it's like you
when you've got other things alongside
the relationships that ah
you can't just
you can't just drop the relationship now
because it mean it's not just you two
liking each other
like it's deeper than that so
like that's why they stay so you think
it's like they're in too deep like they
don't really know she's crazy and then
they get in so deeply
at first at first every really sorry at
first every relationship is good like
at the start
every you wouldn't be in the
relationship if it was if you saw the
red flag straight away or if you like if
you didn't enjoy it at first you're not
going to be in that relationship so
it always the first part of the race
ship's always the best because you're
getting to know each other you're having
the most fun you're trying to like
impress each other
and then as it goes on that's when the
problems you'll see like the red flags
more clearly and you'll
you like that's when the problems start
occurring yeah that no no one's a if if
if you jump into a relationship and the
guy slaps you on the first date
are you gonna marry this guy you're not
so
he's gonna be really friendly and then
he's gonna be more possessive and it's
gonna it's gonna gradually increase to
him being abusive or whatever that's why
but do you think that comes with like an
insecurity like he doesn't want no one
else to have you or any type of thing
because control does have a big effect
on a relationship whether it's like a
small scale or not and it's like how do
you see that from the start like how do
you kind of gauge those kind of red
flags from the beginning like it's
really hard i was gonna say um has uh
it's probably an old tv program it's
based on a true event right have you
ever seen a murder by my boyfriend yeah
so yeah that's crazy yeah
so basically for
you guys have you seen it um
some people haven't seen it basically in
another show they you see so the girl
starts dating this guy
everything everything goes good you have
a kid but then after that you know he
starts like
possessive wouldn't let her out the
and then he get he goes and gets another
girlfriend
while he's with her and when the kid she
goes to um
to find out where she lives next thing
you know he goes into a store where she
works
black and blue differently and then yeah
man like so that's probably like the
perfect program to describe
like it's sad because it starts off
great and it ends up with him killing
her with a ironing board
[Music]
based on true story there's a song
there's a song similar to that have you
heard uh leslie by dave
talks about like domestic violence that
he just talks about like how the girl it
was all perfect like rainbow sunshine
and then there's just like it's a
gradual thing it's not suddenly he just
attacks you of nowhere psych it's like
don't ignore the red yeah yeah don't
ignore the little signs like yeah you
just can't
because at the end of the day everybody
has the right to leave
you know do you do you get what do you
think's worse being physically abused or
emotionally abused i always say
emotionally abused
both of them together at the same time
scars will heal scars
is called that's for life
i always say i would rather someone slap
me
than to say something that would happen
for the rest of my life because i
exactly
want to repeat in relationships play
fighting is like very dangerous because
if a guy gets too comfortable even a
girl gets too comfortable like with
hitting you
um then suddenly when they actually do
hit you once they're mad they don't see
it as that bad yeah
like what happened to me in my past
relationship like the guy used to just
like hit me for fun like play fighting
in the beginning i was kind of like whoa
like but then it got like more and more
and more and i would have like bruises
on my arms and [ __ ] he would grab me as
well and he would just see it as oh no
it's just i'm just playing with you i'm
like bro
don't you see my arms especially because
my skin is lighter right so you can
really see it so what why did why would
you like leave then why don't you you
know i mean
because i was dumb like listen i was in
in that relationship i feel like i was
in a way like emotionally dependent on
him and he manipulated me to the point
where i was actually there while he was
doing the craziness and i was still
there like the tip of the iceberg was
when we had broken up and we hadn't been
together for probably like eight months
and he came to my house and he just
smashed my door like i had a huge hole
in my door because you heard a guy
inside my house i was on facetime with a
guy
he smashed my door
crazy and he thought he didn't think of
it as bad because the next thing
the next day
that was my next question do you think
um abusers like test the water
and like they start kind of like start
they kind of start to see like what
they're capable of
they they tip their toe in a little bit
you know
i feel like a lot of them are smart as
well they're like um
yeah they're like really manipulative
and like make you feel like it's your
fault or gas like what they're doing is
fine and you're
they're the victim even like
they'll make you look crazy yeah like
they'll
they'll be nice to all of your friends
like
like
they're not they're not just they're not
idiots they're like they actually can be
smart people the way they they're so
controlling and yeah
stuff yeah but i just think you have to
be smart if that's what you want to do
you can't
like just like you said on the first
date you can't just go there and just
slap someone because you know that's out
of order but within time you know like i
might just grab her and do this all
right i can get away with that like it's
a thing where
back to my point like you just can't
ignore red flags like if you feel if you
feel some type of way uncomfortable on
one little thing you have to note that
in your head like oh that happened i'm
not cool with it so yeah but i'm not
gonna lie we've all ignored red flags
before and we always hope for the better
but so i don't think anybody can say
like don't ignore red flags or like
because we've all done it well we've all
ignored it the problem is especially as
women were attracted to red flags
because the same thing that make the
same thing that makes a guy like toxic
makes him attractive
so like for example cheating right have
you ever have you guys ever stayed with
a cheater no
it's good for you
really no that's really rare usually
usually one girl will say yes
but like the reason a lot of times girls
do right is because that's a sign of
pre-selection so like girls want a guy
that other girls want
and like the same thing with like like
abuse on some level like like even
though the
i mean we're not attracted to obviously
them like beating our ass like clearly
not but
a guy that has aggression in him like
women are attracted to a guy that can
protect you and it's the same traits
that make the guy the villain make him
the hero but also like the like being
controlling with the girl because in
some cultures like latino culture for
example is seen not like the crazy
control but like him caring and
controlling you a little bit as seen as
like
something you would want
because he's showing you that he cares
but then obviously he can go into the
toxic controlling and it goes further
and further and further yeah go girls
like it when a guy's a little bit
controlling like if he's like come in
now they're like oh like
it's weird
like they like getting like not like
obviously hit like obviously like
physical stuff during like
intimacy like getting slapped in that so
it's like it's true but yeah some girls
like that though some girls lagging
spanx you know getting a little choked
out pulled hair you know i mean like
what i've asked girls this question
before like what's more attractive babe
can you please be quiet or shut the [ __ ]
up
i've said this i've said this on pretty
much i think i've said it on pretty much
every podcast like girls like the guy
that's like if you're going off here and
like yo
and you'll be like listen hey shut the
[ __ ] up breath like and you be and then
nobody girls be like damn like you just
put me in my place it's not fun i don't
like that i like it
i'm not okay with it you're not okay
with it but like put your foot down but
like deetana i'm like whoa like nah but
i know people okay i'll put your
scenario you're you okay so he's done
something wrong right you're snapping on
him like you're going like you're trying
to be the alpha right now like you're
trying to wear the pants right and he
just told you hey listen like he just
showed you like you need to shut the
[ __ ] up but he showed you like in a way
where it's like damn like he put me in
my place
do you guys
have you ever have you ever had a guy
kick you out like you need to get the
[ __ ] out
no no no
i've heard girls say like that's like
the most attractive thing of a guy
you're dare to
you know what's funny that's not
emotionally available you know what's
emotionally fail available saying babe
that bothered me you know it's not
emotionally available baby shut the [ __ ]
up
i don't like that we like this
okay i'm gonna read some super chats um
okay we're ready a long applause a
hundred dollars
oh my gosh okay guys guys i bought a
soundboard off of facebook marketplace
it went poorly i really appreciate these
um and a new camera that's this is going
for um don't forget to like the video
while you're here let's see how many
likes we're at we're at
um
let's see 284 likes can we get to 300
can we get to 300 i think we can
okay let me go up oh no guys
oh my gosh wait okay
okay okay i thought i lost the super
chats because it loaded
um okay 20 super chat from i'm a potato
that is a good username with um an x 10
years i was with an ex for 10 years a
new woman friends
then
a new girlfriend a new woman friend like
maybe a girl came in then the cops were
at my door she said i threw her down the
next protection order was kicked out of
my house three months until the court
date pushed back six more months until i
was proven innocent no punishment to her
oh so she accused him of abuse basically
and he had to wait nine months for the
trial i feel for you bro
and there was no like she even though
she falsely accused him because and she
couldn't like prove it yeah
then like he he still lost he was in his
house for nine months yeah i think the
the fact that
he lost time as well it's kind of peak
is not on our side like the sun the sun
is going to be up regardless you know
what i mean yeah oh my gosh you know
what i've heard about like child i've
heard that in child custody cases
where the woman like won't let the man
see the kids
and the guy has to wait to take her to
court and then he hasn't seen his kid
for six months and then they go to court
and they're like when's the last time
you saw your kid
and he's like six months ago but it's
because of
and so it almost puts them
like but it's interesting because even
in that case i don't know how
because you don't want
because some girls just can't prove they
were abused
you know what i'm saying like it's not
like every girl falsely accuses them
especially when it's like emotional or
like yeah
and plus and like some k in in some like
in like you said in some child cases
like a lot of well
i don't know what the percentage is but
like it's always favors the woman so
like the man hardly ever wins like to
keep the child even like even if he
wants to you know i mean like it's so
it's hardly it's hardly like oh
sorry the court normally favors the
woman to take care of the child because
i don't know for a reason but like
that's that's how it goes
and you know i've i've heard and i i
haven't actually read this study myself
so i don't know if i'm misquoting it but
i've heard that after the age of like
seven men are actually better with kids
because they're more like logical so
it's more structured for the kid where
women like feel different every day but
it's like below the age of seven women
are better with the kids
does that go down to like nurturing
because you know women are natural
nurtures
that kind of thing but
i could see
why kind of yeah but when the baby says
the words are daddy even though you're
the one taking care of it that must hurt
dharma's hurt
like you did all of that for like nine
months and the first one to come out is
that dad
you're holding l's your whole assortment
oh my god i didn't even think about that
you know what's crazy too johnny depp
had his finger severed
by her like she threw a bottle at him
and his finger was severed off like it
came out physical damage
but still
that's that's nice you did that this is
right
imagine if he imagine if he hit her back
like the whole narrative would have been
he hit her
but i i think he should have like do you
guys think he should have hit her back
swing yes or no
you broke up by the cool yeah
what are you what do you guys think in
that situation could he have hit her
back
i'm sorry that's like like you said life
in death situation someone throwing
balls at me yeah absolutely i think
regardless it just shows how
much strength he has mentally
because you always say i would hit it
back he didn't yeah that shows how calm
he is
like that's a lot of strength mentally
i think he embraces jack sparrow a bit
too much he's always like
yeah like you don't know
we don't really know what happened prior
to that so
she
the abuse before that
now it's kind of normal to me it's not
like us hearing that that's shocking
like
his fingers come off but he's been
abused obviously prior to that so it's
like
he's sort of used to it and it's like
you get you get numb to it i guess
like your threshold of what was normal
changes
what do you guys think could he hit her
back
i think he could swing for her a little
bit
humbly hum humble humble come on you've
literally broken a part of me now like
like a humble little writer right to the
left no no no no no one would actually
know what they'd do unless they was in
that situation
but i felt like if it was me
like that's my
i think i would just i would want to
leave
but yeah i don't know i'm not doing i'd
have to be in that situation to know she
would she would hold a humble two-piece
i'm not gonna lie to you yeah that's
crazy yeah
she's trying to kill you like
do you think that women like test men
sometimes to see what they can get away
with 100 percent
that the man needs to set the precedence
and be like that is not acceptable and
depending on how he responds to that
will determine how she respects him a
season for the duration of the
relationship
happened to me once what happened it was
it wasn't tell me the story it was a
little tell us nothing tell us
we're having a debate and it turned into
an argument and as she was storming off
she pushed my head which is nothing
literally
because i have quite an explosive um
disposal personality whenever i'm angry
i'm quite calm i'm i've got a high
tolerance so when it when it peaks it
just it's an explosion so when
even though it was just a push to the
head i could have spoken to her but i
did i literally exploded and i think at
that point
she's referenced that moment like
numerous amount of time so now that she
wouldn't there's a line that she knows
she can't cross so i feel like it's
important for men in those situations or
and women to set boundaries from very
very early on
yeah
yeah i i agree with the early boundaries
100
boundaries you think his girls are we
aware
that we're trying to test them i'm not
talking like just in a normal
relationship i'm not talking abusive but
there's like little things you know
little things like what like um like
they call it in the manosphere they'll
call it like [ __ ] tests
and like pick up so they're kind of like
girls test you to see how you respond to
see like if you're truly like masculine
and dominant
like if you don't tell me off for making
you wait 30 minutes yeah
that's one of them actually
that would be a bad test for me because
i so as i said i have a high tolerance
so if that was a test for me i'd fail it
because i'm very patient so if that's
your measuring stick yeah and you keep
doing that eventually i'm going to
explode and you'll know that that's not
you know what i'm trying to say with
something physical i'm going to respond
immediately but if it's what if it's
making me wait 30 minutes i'm a very
patient person but eventually when i
address it it's going to be with some
sort of rage i think if someone made me
wait 30 minutes like i'll let them know
it's not cool yeah because think about
it now like what if our son
is at school 30 minutes wait
no i see but that's the whole patience
thing because i'm a very punctual guy
like if if you if you tell me be there a
certain time i'll be there like half an
hour earlier out just so i know because
like you know god god forbid it happens
you know just be punctual type thing and
i mean and then like obviously i've got
friends and all that like
other people like a girlfriend
girlfriend
friends um
that'd be like they take their sweet
time
like
and it's it's one of those things where
it's like bro like is that a respect
listen yeah you but you're different you
you get it like not a lot of women do
that that's the that's
like you get it like you know what i
mean be there yeah exactly oh actually
no
truth be told you you always looked out
of the house you
you couldn't leave so you wasn't there
two times boots yeah okay okay yeah i
don't have it i don't have a wallet now
no that's forgiving that's what
forgiveness forgive me but it's just
like some people just like just it's not
hard like for example like you know
black man's time the whole the whole
thing right
if i'm like you know there's there's
there is a there's a thing about being
fashionably late
to a party and then and then yeah this
show you're trying to come in halfway
through you know who you are huh
the guy that was rigging the doorbell
like we're in the middle of the show now
we are in the middle of the show my bro
the time there to be there was nine
o'clock 9 30 start i'm sorry but you did
not make the cuts unfortunately you have
been cut off
no hard feelings don't know how feelings
no but like it's almost like though if
you if you do that with girls and you
like they're going to test you to get i
don't get why why would you why what's
the point of that i don't get that
you're just testing i don't think it's
conscious a lot of the time so you're so
you turn up late intentionally well i
don't i'm i'm i'm punctual i'm gonna be
honest
my mom taught me punctuality there are
some people who do it intentionally yeah
but why like why would you do that
because everything's attached to them
it's like no because it's like they want
to see how much of a man you are like
they want to see if you are can you hold
boundaries yeah can you are you like are
you the type like are you going to
protect your piece protect your space
are you a strong are you a strong guy
there was there was my friend right who
just passed his license right so he um
he got his car and all that stuff he had
the girlfriend
she lives um
outside of london not too sure where she
lives basically she lives in my area she
lives like
30 35 minutes basically she can take a
bus to get to his right
but then i feel like she just kept like
testing whether he's going to compete
like you know pick her up pick her all
the time yeah yeah so and obviously he
like he done it like because he was like
the starter relation but now he's just
like i i feel like i feel like he had to
yes he had to you know be like listen yo
i'm i'm okay with you picking you up
that's not a problem but like you gotta
like make
the trip every now and then you know
honestly it's very attractive when a guy
comes oh yeah opens the door for you
closes looks around yeah
yeah it's very attractive when the guy
is like listen be ready yeah i don't
know 7 p.m i'm coming to pick you up
yeah you know what was it attractive gas
prices okay
actually no that's so true the worst is
like when a guy asks you
like what like what do you yeah like
they want you to plan the date girls
like to know exactly what's going to
happen at this time this time who's
going to be there what i'm going to wear
i just yeah i just want you to say hey i
found this good spot let's go there i'm
going to pick you up at this time now
where do you where do you want to go
what do you want to do
wouldn't you class that as a guy being
controlling and showing that from very
early on
that's not controversial
every aspect of the of the day
including what you're wearing no no yeah
for sure but the more it goes on like if
that continues
and he's always picking the places i
mean it's fine but communication comes
in but we're talking about with like
first time it's like first oh yeah yeah
yeah but let's say let's say it's been
like six months long he's still doing
that but no i kind of like that because
it takes the pressure off of me it's one
thing like it's one that it's one thing
if he says we can't go anywhere else
like i'll tell him if i want if there's
somewhere i really want to try but it's
nice to have a guy make decisions i'm
not like we're not decisive beings we
like it when you guys do it exactly like
don't tell me oh we'll figure it out no
tell me where we're going yeah yeah fair
enough you're sure about it what do you
what do you want to do like you asked me
out
why are you asking me
i feel like yeah if a guy if a guy
genuinely likes you yeah this is where a
girl could see it early
if a guy actually likes you you you
he'll want to take you out on a date
yeah you think of things but imagine how
many girls this guy's talking to he's
not going to take every single one of
them like he's not like he might be rich
i don't know but he's not got that much
time or whatever so he's going to be
like oh china trying to get out like
what are you on basically you would be
surprised how many guys have that much
time
different girls you would be surprised
only the bombs
that's the bums they have a lot of free
they always get the most game though i'm
not even gonna think
they already got a lot of time to like
learn how to
talk now you know what it is i'll say
like for example me i've said this i've
said it in a podcast before um like i'm
an active person right
and i don't mind planning like i've
never minded playing the day so like you
know the where the how the when and all
that stuff but like
different girls are for different vibes
in it like you know i mean like
different girls like different things
you know so like i'm a quite an active
person so for me a date a first day
second or whatever just i any type of
date has to include something like
fun and activity you know i mean so we
can both like you know
bond i'd say you know talk bond and
stuff like that so it's not just like oh
let's just go get some food and like
talk you know i mean that's
dated that's dating active dates are the
best yeah
i need to know how competitive you are
almost i listen to that
as a guy do you let the girl win no no
no what no no i always say this every
time like okay cool i may not win but i
will still give you just the whole time
you will still feel it if you if you
beat the guy is that unattractive that
could give you like the ick or something
but you know it's not enough because no
no no because you know you say that's
unattractive yeah but you'd be like like
you you keep trying to say something to
me like shut up man i beat you don't do
that don't don't have a chat okay cool
let's let's say you go let's say you go
bowling now on a date yeah and he tries
to throw it and he falls or something
like and he's just bad that he can't
bowl he gets like zero and then you you
like your decent eye level yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly exactly like straight
away take me off i swear
like i'm not good at it i can't imagine
imagine he's really bad like yeah but
imagine if i was really bad and he's
looking at me like
like but a guy's not going to really
look at he's got he didn't really care
if she's bad at golf i don't care like i
find out like it's like you know i find
that you know what he's here you know
what he's here golfi is actually a
really good example you know because for
girls bad yeah that just invites the man
to get touchy feely and show how it's
done you know what i'm saying
you know i'm saying that bro you'd be
like oh she should be trying to swing
she's missing the baby like her baby let
me show you and i'm saying you get your
hips low you're good it's like how many
days you've been on top
you know what i enjoy doing i enjoy
beating guys at basketball that's my
thing because i enjoy beating guys at
basketball because i'm actually good
it's true like we i went i went to one
scrimmage with her right
and it's on youtube but we in that
youtube video we was made look bad right
but in the actual game right yeah we
have not we want we walked in that game
we did not lose one game i just keep
giving her the ball and she was bullying
people inside bullying these boys oh my
gosh
i was no but they edited it out they
edited they had a youtube video and they
filmed me posting up on these guys and
killing them and they edited all of that
out and only put the shots i missed that
was so irritated that's a vital i was i
was bodying these boys
but we gotta go around too though for
real um
yeah i know we gotta go back
okay i'm gonna read some super chats
okay